[موسيقى]
على هذه المشاركه في اعمال القمه الثامنه
عشره للمنظمه الدوليه للفرانكفورنيا في
جزيره جربه التونسيه اعترف الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل
حقيقيا للغه الفرنسيه في بلدان المغرب
العربي خلال العقود الماضيه لصالح اللغه
الانجليزيه التي تتميز حسب تعبيره بسهوله
الاستعمال اكثر من لغه مولير هذا التراجع
يتطلب وفق رؤيه الرئيس مكرونه اعداد
مشروعا لاستعاده مكانه اللغه الفرنسيه في
البلدان في هذه البلدان تحديدا وتعزيز
حضورها على شبكه الانترنت في المنظمات
الدوليه من خلال المرهنه على التعليم
والثقافه والرياضه باعتبارها رافعات قويه
للفرانكفونيه فما هي اسباب هذا التراجع
المستمر للغه الفرنسيه في المنطقه
المغاربيه وفي بلدان الافريقيه الاخرى وهل
ينجح الرئيس الفرنسي في استراتيجيته
الجديده لدعم الفرانكونيه في ظل التحديات
التي تواجهها اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من
سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
مفارقه حقيقيه اثرتها قمه الدول
الفرانكفورنيا التي عقدت مطلع هذا الاسبوع
في تونس فاعداد الناطقين باللغه الفرنسيه
في تزايد بسبب النمو الديمغرافي خاصه في
الدول الافريقيه لكن اعداد المستخدمين في
تناقص وهما يؤكده ايضا توجه دول مغربيه
وافريقيه نحو ادراج اللغه الانجليزيه في
مناهج التعليم الابتدائيه وفي الفضاءات
العامه عن اسباب تراجع اللغه الفرنسيه في
البلدان المغاربيه ومستقبلها في هذه
البلدان وفي غيرها من البلدان المنضويه
تحت رايه الفرنكوفنيه يسعدنا ان يكون معنا
في هذه الحلقه من تونس مهدي مبروك وزيره
الثقافه التونسيه الاسبق ومدير المركز
العربي للابحاث ودراسه السياسات بتونس
وسينضموا الينا لاحقا من العاصمه الشاديه
وزير التربيه السابق ومعنى من باريس سلام
الامين العام الاداري للجمعيه البرلمانيه
للفرانكفورنيا
الفرانكفونيه هي رحله عبر الزمن والقارات
ويجب ان تتبنى مشروعا لاستعاده اللغه
الفرنسيه هكذا قال الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون في لقاء جربه الفرانكفورنيا واوضح
ان التحدي الحقيقي للفرانكفونيه واعاده
لغه مليارد الى طبعها العالمي
[موسيقى]
الى قمه الفرانكو فنيه في تونس جاء الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون مناديا الى تدارك
تقهقر لغه بلاده في جزء مهم من مستعمراتها
السابقه
حدد ماكرون اسباب ذلك في ما وصفها باشكال
من المقاومه شبه السياسيه للغه الفرنسيه
وتلك قراءه في عمق الظاهره التي لا تنحصر
ابعادها في الجانب المعرفي فقط بلها جوانب
اخرى تتعلق بالموقف السياسي
وبالايديولوجيا وبالمشاعر المكنونه اذا
الماضي لاستعماري الفرنسي
جامعا للدول الناطقه باللغه الفرنسيه
تقف اليوم امام تحدي كبير في الحفاظ على
مكانه الفرنسيه في الخريطه الديموغرافيه
في ظل ميول بينه للغه الانجليزيه في
المستعمرات الفرنسيه السابقه وابرزها دول
المغرب العربي
[موسيقى]
الجزائر وان لم تكن عضو في تجمع
الفرانكفورنيا الا ان تقرير للمنظمه هذا
العام الشراء الى ان نحو 15 مليون جزائري
من مجمل 45 مليون يتحدثون اللغه الفرنسيه
لكن السلطات هناك اقرت هذه السنه في تحول
اللافت تعليم اللغه الانجليزيه في المرحله
الابتدائيه وذاك ما كانت تستاثر به اللغه
الفرنسيه منذ استقلال البلاد عن فرنسا
تبدو توجهات السياسيه الجديده الان داعمه
للذهاب نحو تعدديه لغويه تنهي هيمنه اللغه
الفرنسيه
في المغرب مثل ذلك تميل الاجيال الجديده
الى اعطاء الاولويه في التعلم للغه
الانجليزيه
ويعتقد ان هذا التحولات تمليه اضافه الى
عالميه الانجليزيه ظروف اقتصاديه مؤثره
فتوسع نشاط الشركات الامريكيه والبريطانيه
وحتى الخليجيه واستثماراتها في المغرب
تزيد الحاجه الى اللغه الانجليزيه
باعتبارها مؤهلا مهما للعمل في هذه
الشركات
تميل الاجيال الجديده بشكل عام اذا الى
تعلم اللغه الانجليزيه وحتى لغات شرقيه
مثل الصينيه والتركيه
ويعتقد ملاحظون لنشاط المنظمه لفرانكونيه
انها ظلت تجسد تجمعا للمستعمرات الفرنسيه
القديمه دون ان تتحول الى منظومه اقتصاديه
او تكسب الدول الاعضاء فيها حضورا سياسيا
في النظام الدولي وبين اقدام الاقتصاد
العالمي
ورغم ان المنظمه الدوليه للفرانكفونيه لم
تتحول الى منظومه اقتصاديه فقد طرحت فكره
الفرنكفونيه الاقتصاديه عام 2014 في قمه
ذكاء بالسنغال لكنها لم تجد طريقها بعد
التنفيذ ومنذ عام
1986 تجتمع قمه الفرانكفورنيا كل عامين
على مستوى الرؤساء الدول والحكومات
الناطقه باللغه الفرنسيه
والمضويه في المنظمه الدوليه
للفرانكفورنيا المزيد عن هذه المنظمه
واهدافها في هذه الورقه التعريفيه
اسست المنظمه الدوليه للفرانكفونيه عام
1970 في النيجر ويوجد مقرها في باريس تضم
حاليا 88 دوله من بينها 54 دوله عضو 27
تتمتع بصفه مراقب
وتقدر المنظمه عدد الناطقين باللغه
الفرنسيه في العالم ب 321 مليون شخص وتقول
ان اهدافها الرئيسيه تتمثل في تعزيز اللغه
الفرنسيه والتنوع الثقافي واللغوي ودعم
التعليم كما تهدف المنظمه حسما ورد في
ميثاق تاسيسها الى الاسلام في تحسين مستوى
عيش شعوب البلدان الممثله فيها وتنظيم
العلاقه بينها وتنفيذ برامج مختلفه لصالح
الناطقين بالفرنسيه كما يتركز عمل المنظمه
على ايجاد فرص للتبادل التجاري بين فرنسا
والدول الاعضاء في المنظمه وحث المجموعه
الفرانكفونيه على اتخاذه مواقف مماثله
تجاه القضايا والقرارات التي تمس مصالح
فرنسا
وعلى الرغم من بعض الاصوات الناقده لاداء
المنظمه لفرانكفونيه فقد رات السيد لويز
موشي كيابو التي اعيد انتخابها للمره
الثانيه امينه عامه خلال الاربع سنوات
المقبله ان المنظمه باتت اكثر اهميه من اي
وقت مضى وقالت انها تتطلع الى فرانكفونيه
متجدده معاشره واكثر ملائمه في عالم متعدد
الاخطاء موضحا ان دور الفرانكفونيه هو
ضمان استمرار لغه الفرنسيه في احتلال
مكانتها داعيه الى الاستثمار في التعليم
الفرنسي وتحصينه في القاره الافريقيه
وقالت انها ستطلب من الدول الاعضاء مضاعفه
جهودها في مواجهه تراجع اللغه الفرنسيه في
المنظمات الدوليه
وكان رئيسي مانويل ماكرون قد قدم تحت قبه
الاكاديميه الفرنسيه استراتيجيته
للفرانكفورنيا
جاعلا تطوير اللغه الفرنسيه في العالم من
اولويات سياساته الدوليه وقال امام طلاب
من جامعه اوغدوغو خلال زيارته لبركنا فاسو
عام 2017 ستكون الفرنسيه هي اللغه الاولى
لافريقيا وربما في العالم اذا عرفنا كيف
نقوم بذلك في العقود المقبله فلنحمل هذا
التحدي معا هيا بنا لنبدا في تنفيذ
نرحب بضيفينا من باريس وتونس ونبدا بسيد
مهدي مبروك اذا انطلقنا مما قاله مكروعا
تراجع اللغه الفرنسيه في المنطقه
المغاربيه وفي افريقيا عموما كيف ترى
الاسباب
الفرنسيه تتراجع مكانتها في دول المغرب
العربي لاسباب عديده
ساذكر منها بايجاز اربعه اسباب هامه اولا
سيبدا بسياسات التعليم التي اتبعتها دول
المغرب العربي اتباعا منذ تقريبا
الثمانينات وكان له طبعا هذا همم
اثر على مكانه اللغه الفرنسيه وهي سياسات
تعريب ولكن ايضا في نفس الوقت سياسه تعدد
لغوي اي ذهبنا في المغرب العربي من
ازواجهه اللسان بين العربيه والفرنسيه الى
تعدد الالسن بدليل ان لغه الانجليزيه مثلا
في تونس وفي الجزائر وفي المغرب همم الان
مكانه على حساب اللغه
الفرنسيه حين اذا ذهبنا من كما قلت من
احاديث اللغه القديمه الى ثنائيه ازدواجيه
اللغه الى تعدد لغه واعتقد ان سياسات
التعليم والتعدد اللغوي كان لها هذا الاثر
الامر الثاني اعتقد يعود الى تكوين
المدرسين في دول المغرب العربي وانا اتحدث
عن مساله بيداغوجيا اللغه الفرنسيه على قد
ان طيفا واسعا من المدرسين الذين يدرسون
باللغه الفرنسيه عفوا في سواء في المرحله
الابتدائيه او في المرحله الثانويه
التعليمهم وادائهم البيداغوجي يحتاج
ويعتقد ان اليونسكو اشارت في كم مره الى
هذه المعضله والمعذله الثالثه اعتقديه من
معدل بنوويه تتعلق باللغه الفرنسيه ذاتها
اللغه الفرنسيه للاسف لم تعد لغه الجماعات
العلميه في مجال سواء في مجال العلوم
الصحيحه او في مجال العلوم الانسانيه
بدليل ان الفرنسيه ذاتهم اذا ما ارادوا
مثلا ان يحسنوا من ترتيب الجامعات
الفرنسيه يذكرني الى الكتابه باللغه
الانجليزيه وهناك الان جود داخل الجماعات
العلميه الفرنسيه لكي تكتب باللغه
الانجليزيه احنا اذا لم تعد مثلا يحتذى في
الكتاب والانتاج العلمي والانتاج المعرفي
والامل اعتقد ان المساله ايضا تعود الى
مساله سياسات لغويه تتبع فرنسا ما لم اا
اا تدرك فرنسا
انسل لغتها يحتاج الى تعاون اقتصادي وان
الامر اذا ما ظل يعني المنظمه العالمي
للفلكوريا واذا ظلت الجهود
مختزله فقط في نشر الفرنسيه دون ادراجها
في تعاون اقتصاد اجمل مع الدول فان الامر
يبدو في الكثير من الاحيان رغبه في
الهيمنه الثقافيه والسياسيه بلا مقابل
ويعرب الجميع ان مرسى الموسوس يتحدث عن
الهبه ومقابل اهليبه حين اذا ما الذي
تمنحه الى فرنسي محمد انه في ال- ال-
السنوات الاخيره جون ان نكبر الجامعي في
المغرب العربي ليس الحق في التاشيره يعني
تصور ان هذه النخبه التي تراها عليها
فرنسا تعاقب واعتقد ان احد احد المفارقات
التي التي قدمت في القمه الفونيه ان من
الجامعين ارادوا زياره فرنسي لاسباب
العلميه واذا بهم في ذات في ذات المناسبه
لا تحظى قبول تاشيرات احنا اذا يبدو ان
الامر الطموح لفرنسا ان تنشر لغتها ولكن
اعتقد بهذه المناهج وبهذه الكيف وبهذه
الروح لا يمكن في اعتقادي ان تنهض اللغه
الفرنسيه وان تستعيد مكانتها في المغرب
العربي او في دول اخرى واعتقد ان حين اذا
سوت تتبعيه وسوره الالحاق الثقافي لا زالت
تلاحق اللغه الفرنسيه ما لم تراجع فرنسا
سياستها اللغويه وموقفها من الدول الهيمنه
والتبعيه اعتقد ان هي احدى الصور النبطيه
الذي التي لا زالت تلاحق الفرانكونيه في
دول المغرب العربي وفي دول افريقيا بصفه
عامه
الي في فرنسا يمكن في حقيقه الامر ان
تستعد نعم يعني من بين هذه الاسباب
الكثيره المعقده لنرى السيد دميان سيسيلان
من بينهم ما هي الاسباب التي يراها ربما
اكثر قوه في تفسير تراجع اللغه الفرنسيه
اربعه ثمانيه
بالعربي همم
وايضا مصر
بالتاكيد متنوعه من الواضح ان اللغه
الفرنسيه في تراجع
باللغه الانجليزيه التي اصبحت اللغه
التواصل في عالم المعونه حاليا والجميع
تقنيه يتحدثون بهذه اللغه وهي طبعا لغه
سهله التعلم ايضا
ومن الصعب بالنسبه للغه الفرنسيه الدخاومه
هذا اللغه والاخر الشهر
الاول في كل العالم
كل الدول
عن اللغه الفرنسيه وايضا العمل لنا في
المجتمعات المدنيه ايضا هناك دائما بعض
الموادرات الصغيره والمحليه وذلك للمحافظه
على اللغه الفرنسيه
وان الضيف الاخر تحدث فعلا عن تاثير
المتزايد للغه الانجليزيه في مجال العلوم
والانترنت وهذا طبعا ينطبق على معظم
المعارف خاصه المعارف القانونيه وتعليم
القانون هذه استاذ استخدام اللغه
الانجليزيه فيها هذا حقيقه لابد انعيها
وان نحاول مواجهتها لا هذا ينطلق ليس
اللغه الفرنسيه
حول
عالميه همم ولكن ايضا تحدث عالميه اللغات
لان هذه جزء من الثراء الانسانيه
في العمل لغه واحده يجعل العالم فقيرا
اللغه الفرنسيه ايضا تستفيد من القوه عنصر
القوه
الافريقيه الساحر منطقه الساحل
الديموغرافيه ناكله ومتنوعه والتالي
بالامكانيات كبير في مستقبل متحدين باللغه
الفرنسيه لكن هذا اللي يحصل تلقائيا لذلك
هناك السياسه قويه على في مجال الثقافي
والتعليمي من الابتدائيه الى جامعه لتعليم
اللغه الفرنسيه والاجعل الناس يرغبون
بتعلم اللغه الفرنسيه
قد يتخللنا على الفرنسيه ويتعلمون
الانجليزيه اكثر من الفرنسيه اذا هذه
حقيقه لا تجعل لابد تجعل لابد ان
السلطات السياسيه بشكل جيد من قبل
الحكومات
للتطبيق السياسات التعليميه ثقافيه
دكتور مهدي مبروك قال له وزير التعليم
التونسي السابق جلول يقول وهنا انا
اقتباس يقول همم او
بالاحرى الفرانكفورنيا لم لم تستطع التحول
الى منظومه اقتصاديه وثقافيه وانما بقيت
تجسد مجمعا للمستعمرات الفرنسيه السابقه
الى اي مدى هذا صحيح خاصه اذا اخذنا ان
بعض النخب في المنطقه المغاربيه تحسب على
انها همم النخبه همم متفرسه
وغريبه عن المجتمع وربما هذا ساهم في مزيد
تهيج مشاعر ربما معينه ضد ضد اللغه
الفرنسيه
نعم هذا واضح اعتقد انه كما قلت حينما
تختزل المنظمه العالميه للفرنفونيه هدفها
الاكبر نشر اللغه الفرنسيه متجاهله اهميه
المساهمه الاقتصاديه في النهوض بهذا
البلدان والتعاون والتوفيق التبادل
الثقافي والاقتصادي بالاساس وجعل الفضاء
الفضاء للجولان الحر للكفاءات والتشغيل
اعتقد ان كما قلت هذا سيؤدي تماما الى
تحول المنظمه العالمي للفراخونيه الى نوع
من الهيمنه وارادات الهيمنه والبسط وبسط
اللغه فقط ولذلك كما قلت جابها في الكثير
من الاحيان بهذا الصدر الامر الثاني اعتقد
انه لنا في المغرب العربي مشكل الحقيقي مع
انه قبل فرانفونيه وليس مع الفرنسيه
الفرنسيه
هو بالعكس قيمه مضافه ولكن اعتقد لنا في
المغرب العربي مشكل الحقيقه علينا ان ان
ان ان ان ان ان نتحدث فيه بكل صراحه هي ان
نخبي الفرنكنيه هذه النخبه التي تستعير
عفوا تشعر بان هويتها عار وانها عبء عليها
وبالتالي نوع من تمارس نوع من الاستعلاء
والاستلحاق الثقافي همم الذي لا مبرر له
واعتقد ان الفونين للاسف بين وكانهم غاليه
همم
تعيش في مناخات اخرى
وتنظر الى الثقافه العربيه والهويه
والمجتماعات المحليه بالكثير من الذرات
فعدتك ان المشكله هنا لذلك في الكثير من
الاحيان تواجه اللغه الفرنسيه ليس كالغها
ولكنها كما قلت كان مت كان مت من الحياه
كلمات من التفك اسلوب وكما واقف لذلك كما
قلت كثير من الاحيان يفعل الخلق بين لغه
الفرنسيه وهي اللغه الجميله حقيقه وبين ان
ان نخبي الفرانفونيه في المغرب العربي
التي تريد نوع من الاستلحاد ان تلحق هذه
المجتمعات ب- ب- بفرنسا لذلك فعلا اعتقد
ان جزء من الصور النمطيه حول اللغه
الفرنسيه هي موقف الفرنسيين انه قبل
فرانفونيه من الثقافه المحليه سوما كان في
المغرب سواء كان في الجزائر سواء كان في
تشاد هم جاليات بالفعل وهم يمارسون اكثر
انواع التبديل اللغه العربيه وفي الحق
اللاويه ولذلك ولذلك فعلا المشكله ليس فقط
مشكل بدغوجي او مشكل امكانيات مشكل مزدوج
يتعلق بالتحويل الفضاء
للتشغيل ولذلك همم يعني الشباب لو سالت اي
شاب همم تونسي او في او عفوا او مغربي او
جزائري ما هي اللغه التي تعتقد ان تمن فرص
اكثر للتشغيل في العالم يعني سيقول لك
الانجليزيه والذلك هناك هجره مكثفه لتعلم
اللغات وتحديدا اللغه الانجليزيه واللغه
الالمانيه وتشهد وتشهد المراكز الثقافيه
الان في دول المغرب العربي على هذه
الديناميه التي يهاجر فيها الشباب الطامح
الى همم الشغل يعني والتامح الى ان يجد له
موقع قدم في في في سوق الكفاءات وسوق
الجدارات يذهب كما قلت الى اللغه
الانجليزيه واللغه همم
او غيره من اللغات الاخرى مش كل
الفرنفونيه ما لم تتحول الى فضاء اقتصادي
شامل يعني
واختزاله في اللغه فقط وما لم تتصالح ان
نخبي الفرنفونيه مع هويته ولا تمارس هذا
الاستعلاء الثقافي والرغبه الملحه في
الحقيقه من موقع التبعيه هنا اذن همم
المشكل السيده الهيكلي وستظل الفرانكفونيه
وتصادل اللغه الفرنسيه تتراجع من حين الى
اخر في دول المغرب العربي ولا اعتقد ان
الامر ايضا يختلف كثيرا في عده دول
افريقيه اخرى همم نود ان نعتذر ان ضيفنا
الصديق ابو بكر شوما وزير التربيه للاسف
لم يستطع ان يلتحق بنا كما اعلنا في
البدايه لاسباب فنيه معقده على كل نعتذر
لذلك نسال ضيفنا سيد دميها سلسله عن هذه
النقطه همم وهي همم ان الكثير ينظر الى
هذه القصه قصه الفرانكفونيه مثل ما اثار
ضيفنا من تونس الى قضيه خاصه وان هناك ارث
استعماله مع افريقيا ومع المنطقه
المغاربيه من الصعب نسيانه وبالتالي كيف
يمكن همم ان نجمع بين محاوله دعم اللغه
الفرنسيه وهذا الشعور بان الامر فيه بعض
الوص وحتى بعض الاستعلام همم له جذور
استعماريه سابقه
مش مشكله
ان الضيف السابق قدم رؤيا عن
الفرانكفورنيا
ليست لا تعود الى 2022
وهو لو هناك رؤيه الاستعماريه فعلا وان
هذا حصل في نهايه القرن التاسع عشر عندما
اعزت همم فرنسا
نهايه السنوات
والسبعينات لمحاوله البلقاء على صله بين
المستعمرات فرنسيه قديمه او البلجيكيه
التي حصلت على الاستقلال بطريقتين وذلك
لمحافظه على تبادل الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
والثقافي والمعلومات والسماح لهذه الدول
بتمتع باستقلالها ثم هناك
المؤسسينه للفرانكفورنيا لا نكونوا فرنسيه
كانوا اشخاصا من فارقه من المغرب من منطقه
الساحل الافريقي
وبالتالي هذه كانت اول مرحله من المفرق
الالكترونيه كمؤسسه وعدد ذلك هناك مرحله
ثانيه اعتبارا من عام 2000 حيث
الذي
الدول فرانكفونيه اما بعد حقوق الانسان
والحريه الفرديه
ضد همم ولم تستطيع ان نقدر هناك
فرنسا تفرض نموذج
لا تعمل بهذا الشكل انا امارس هذا العمل
كموظف وانا موظفه اقدم البرلمانيين في
العالم
رئيس المؤسسه
الرئيس الاول له هو رئيس معين عام الغابون
وهمم لجاننا وشبكتنا تاسع عدسه اثناء
اللجنه واحده همم راس البرلمانيون غير
فرنسيه اذا مصطلح الهيمنه الذي استخدمها
الضيف السابق اعتقد غير يبتعد عن الحقيقه
بل على العكس اعتقد ان الفرانكونيه اليوم
تتعلق به
ومحاوله ايجاد حلول
التوصل الى حلول المحليه تتناسب مع ظروفهم
الخاصه لذلك تحديد تاثيرات التغيرات
المناخيه والعمل بطريقه توصل الى اقتصاد
دائم مستدام يمكن ان يؤدي الى تنميه
الشامله تحترم البيئه وهناك مخاطر اخرى
وحاليا ندعي ااا لدينا شبكه ال ال
الاوضئه همم الامراض المنتشره وعام
مواجهتها بشكل مشترك هناك مخاطر اخرى
وكل الدول في
الجمعيه الالمانيه
هم دول حره
في مجال التنميه والتعاون المشترك في
مجلات المختلفه على كل رئيس الفرنسي اعرب
عن وجود برنامج
لاسترداد مكانه اللغه الفرنسيه كما قال
وان التحدي الحقيقي الان تعزيز استخدام
اللغه الفرنسيه خاصه في القاره الافريقيه
تمكنا اخيرا من ان يلتحق بنا الصديق ابو
بكر شومه ولكن عبر الهاتف وهو وزير تربيه
شادي السابق نريد الان ان نقود في امكانيه
ان ان تستعيد اللغه الفرنسيه
مكانتها في في افريقيا على الاقل في جنوب
الصحراء وانت تحدثنا من جمينا هل هل هناك
فرص لها في هذا الاتجاه
يبدو للاسف
الفرنسيه
همم اللغه الفرنسيه دخلت الى هذه المناطق
خاصه المناطق
الممتده من جيبوتي الى السلام في هذه
المناطق توجد لغه اخرى اللغه العربيه
موجوده فدخلت اللغه الفرنسيه والى
للاسف انقطع الصوت
ليس لها حظ مع
الصديق ابو بكر لا لا عبر الصوره ولا عبر
الهاتف اذا نعتذر مره اخرى نعود الى السيد
مهدي مبروك عندما نتحدث عن هذه
الاستراتيجيه الجديده لمكروم يعني كيف
يمكن له ان ينجح فيها اذا كانت اصلا كانت
فرنسا الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه والامنيه في القاره الافريقيه
في تراجع كيف يمكن ان ان ان ان ان ان يمزج
او ان يجمع بين تراجع دور سياسي وعسكري
وتقدم لغوي
نعم هذا السؤال مهم ولكن اسمح لي اسم محمد
ان اجيب ضيفك الكريم انني لم ااه لم اتهم
الفرنفونيه بانها
استعمار ولم اتهم ايضا فرنسا بانها
استعمار قائم انا حضرت على فكره انا وزير
ثقافه وحضرت عده مؤتمرات وقمم للمنظمه
العالميه الفلسطينيه واعي تماما ولكن
استعملت كلمه الهيمنه والهيمنه مستعمله في
العلوم السياسيه واعتقد انه يعني لا يمكن
تماما ان ننفي او ننكر تماما عن فرنسا وعن
اي منظمات اقليميه همم رغبه الهيمنه طبعا
هناك اهداف نبيله للفرانفونيه وانا كما
ذكرت منذ البدايه اعشق يعني همم بالعكس
استلطف اللغه الفرنسيه
واستعملها في بحوث العلميه واكتب بها
وانشرته بها ولكن ميز تماما بين اللغه
الفرنسيه وبين المنظمه العالمي لفرنفونيه
وقلت في الكثير من الاحيان وراء هذه
النوايت طيب هناك رغبه في الهيمنه من نخب
فرانكفوني وانا اي تماما
طيب اجيبك عن السؤال كيف يمكن للغه
الفرنسيه ان تستعيد مكانتها همم في هذا
المشهد اللغوي المتعدد وبالفعل يعني نحن
نخسر تماما حينما تتراجع اي لغه وكان كان
بيودينا ايضا لو انه همم اللغه العربيه
تستعيد مكانتها وتتاقلم الى غير ذلك وعود
ان يعني نتباهى بانتشار اللغه الانجليزيه
عن حساب اللغه الفرنسيه ان اقول اللغه
العربيه لغه العصر واصبحت لغه الجماعه
العلميه الى غير ذلك
الدكتور مبروك
كانت هناك عريضه همم على مواقع التواصل
وقع مجموعه لا باس بها من اساتذه وشعراء
وكتاب موزع الى الى الرئيس سعيد يتحدثون
فيها عن ضروره اعاده الاعتبار للغه
العربيه
وتجنب هذا الخلط اللغوي بين العربيه
والفرنسيه على لسان المسؤولين وفي وسائل
الاعلام وهم يستاجرون هذا هذا التوجه في
في قضيه الاستعمال اللغه الفرنسيه
والعربيه في نفس الوقت
الشارع لغه الاشهار
لغه وسائل الاعلام الى غير ذلك تؤكد ان
هذه الهجانه اللغويه للاسف
تحمل وراءها يعني الكثير من
الرغبه في تبديد قلبه جميل في اللغات ما
هو جميل في اللغه العربيه ما هو جميل في
اللغه الفرنسيه الان يتم تبديده باذن الله
الهجانه اللغويه
اذا ما ارادت اللغه الفرنسيه ان تستعيد
مكانها اعتقد ان هناك ثلاثه شروط اساسيه
لاستعاده اللغه اولا اصلاحات من داخل
اللغه الفرنسيه يعني من الجميع اللغه ان
اللغه الانجليزيه مثلا في الثمانينات
والتسعينات قامت بنوع من القاموسيه
والمعجميه وحصلت تقريبا ما يسمى المشهد او
او القاموس المتداول ما بين سته الاف
ثمانيه الاف لغه وهناك دوائر تتسع الى حدك
وانت سيد العارفين في هذا اذا حقيقه مثلا
2000 الى ثلاثه انت تستطيع ان واذا واذا
كده اعتقد ان هذا غائب في اللغه الفرنسيه
في همم في في تعلميه اللغه الفرنسيه هناك
مشكل الحقيقي بداغوجي ولذلك هذا هذا الامر
متروك الى اصلاحات همم الجذريه في بنيه
اللغه الفرنسيه
والتخليص من كل الزوائد الى الى غير ذلك
وهناء هذا المسائل السوني اللغه ويتعلم
يدك تيك في اللغه الفرنسيه ذاتها حتى تصبح
لغه متداوله لغه معصره الى جلاله وهذا
قامت به العديد من اللغات الاخرى حينما
قلصت من تورمها اللغوي
وحصرته في معجم الحد الادنى الذي يمكن ثم
يتوسع هكذا وهذا لم يحدث في اللغه
الفرنسيه
والمختصين في اللغه الفرنسيه يدركون هذا
اللعبه وهذا الحرج في مراجعه بنيه اللغه
الفرنسيه حتى تصبح حتى يمكن تعلمها باك
يسر
والسيد الرئيس
ماكرون يعترف بان يقول اللغه الانجليزيه
اكثر يسرا ما هو هذا اليسر هو جزء من جسر
اللغه الانجليزيه في هذه الاصلاحات التي
قام بها علماء مختصون في اللغه الانجليزيه
الامر الثاني اعتقد وانه هذا مهم جدا
يعني وانا اعود الى مارسيل موس
كونتر حينما تريد وتحرس فرنسا على ان او
المناظمه العالميه الفرق الفنيه على ان
تتعلم الشعوب افريقيا وشعوب المغرب العربي
الفرنسي لماذا هل لمجرد تعلم اللغه
والكتابه بها هذا الامر اصبح من الماضي
الان الناس يتعلمون من اجل نشر العلمي من
اجل الشغل من اجل همم تحقيق التنميه
والتبادل الاقتصادي ما لم ترتبط السياسات
اللغويه بالتبادل والاقتصادي والتنميه فان
الامر كما كنت مجرد نص تلجا مجرد يعني
رغبه في التكلم باللغه الفرنسيه او قراءه
الادب الفرنسي الى غير ذلك حين اذن على
فرنسا ان تعي تماما ان السياسات اللغويه
اصبحت مرتبطه ارتباطا وثيقا بالسياسات
التنمويه وبقدره وبرقبه الاجيال التي
تتعلم على ان يكون
الزاد اللغوي زاد
للتشغيل يعني هو ارق اسماء لغوي من اجل
الاستثمار والتوظيف في التشغيل والتنميه
التشغيل على المستوى الافراد والجماعات
والتنميه على مستوى الامم والمجتمعات
والامر الثالث كما قلت واعود اليه هي قضيه
الوصايه التي تمارسها الفونيه وتمثل
وتمارسه فرنسا من خلال ان نخبل التي زرعت
والتي لا زالت تحرس على ان باسم التفوق
اللغوي تمارس التفور
الثقافي تمارس التفوق السياسي وبالتالي هي
تمارس نوع من التفوق بين قوسين السياسي
اللغوي على المجتمع الاصلي وعلى بقاء وعلى
بقيه فئات الشعب الناس يشعرون وكان النخبي
الفرنكونه اهي اقليات هي اقليات فرنسيه
داخل المجتمعات المحليه واعود الى ذلك لم
يكن من لم يكن من الصدفه مثلا لم يكن من
الصدفه الان هذا الذجر اللغوي والضجر
والقلق السياسي فليندر ضيفك الى ما يرفع
في نيجيري الى ما يرفع في مالي الى ما
يرفع في عده مجتمعات ارفعي ايديكي في
فرنسا عن مستقبلنا نحن قدر بمستقبلنا ونحن
نادرك بالخير الذي نريد
هذه الحركه همم
اؤكد على ان اللغه الفرنسيه لغه جميله
ولكن نعم يعني هذه الحركيه ربما بارزه
اكثر في في افريقيا السودان كما
ينضم الينا الان ان شاء الله تكون الامور
تمام الصديق ابو بكر شلونه من من جمنا
صديق ابو بكر شلون اهلا وسهلا بك همم كنت
تتحدث همم عن همم برايك كيف يمكن لي اللغه
الفرنسيه ان تستعيد مكانتها في في افريقيا
كما تريدها فرنسا ولكن ايضا هناك وجهه نظر
للسكان لوجود النظر للراي العامل الافريقي
كيف ينظر الى هذه المساله
حقيقه اللغه الفرنسيه متواجده في هذه
الدول ذكرت انها دخلت من خلال الاستعمار
دخلت في شمال افريقيا دامت الى اكثر من
قرن في في في الجزائر على حسب الانسان
وجدت اللغه العربيه همم في مواجهه هذه في
مواجهتها في هذه المناطق ايضا افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء مناطق مثل من جيبوتي الى
السنغال ايضا هذه المناطق توجد فيها لغات
محليه اضافه الى الثقافه العربيه
الاسلاميه التي كانت متجزره في هذه
البلدان دخلت اللغه الفرنسيه وجدت مناخا
لا يساعدها في النمو بصوره عاجله بقيت
اللغه الفرنسيه اللغه
حضريه همم الى يومنا هذا اللغه الفرنسيه
همم لا تتجاوز
ال17% همم في بعض الدول بعضها بين 10 الى
13-12% ننتقل الى ناطق همم الجنوب الى
ابعد من هذه المناطق ال- ال- الساحليه همم
نجد اللغه الفرنسيه منتشره اكثر اذا اخذنا
الكاميرون الغابون الكونغ الديمقراطيه الى
اخره هي لغه مستعمله الى حد كبير همم لكن
اللغات المحليه ايضا متواجده اللغه
الفرنسيه تزحمها اللغه الانجليزيه في هذه
البلدان بدات في الزحور في الزهور رويدا
رويدا بعض الدول يعني اعتمدت اللغه
الانجليزيه كالغه ثانيه
والبعض يعني يحاول ان يدخل الحاجات
المحليه ايضا وبالتاليف ان اللغه الفرنسيه
قد لا ترد على احتياجات المواطنين في هذه
البلدان من همم همم البحث العلمي من
الالتحاق بالجامعات ذات السمعه العاليه
الى اخره لكن في الوقت ذاته تجد للفرنسيه
حضور في هذه البلدان
والنمو اللغه الفرنسيه اذا ما همم اعتمدنا
ما التقرير الاخير لمنظمه الفرانكفونيه
التي يعد في همم لمده اربع سنين من بين
همم 18/2018 الى 2022 نجد ان هناك انه في
هذه المناطق اللي هي اللغه الفرنسيه الى
15% في هذه المناطق خلال هذه السنوات
الاربعه اللغه الفرنسيه من بين يعني تجد
من بين 321 مليون متحدث باللغه الفرنسيه
في العالم
255 مليون يتحدثونها في افريقيا لذلك نرى
ان لي الفرنسيه وجود وجود قوي جدا ولا
نعتقد ان ظهور يعني همم اللغه الانجليزيه
كاللغه ثانيه قد يهدد اللغه الفرنسيه ولكن
همم سيد همم صديق ابو بكر
يعني عطفا على ما قاله الدكتور مهدي مبروك
من ان الفرانكفونيه او فرنسا اذا لم تدمج
قصه السعي لنشر اللغه
بعمليه تنمويه بعلاقات اقتصاديه بمشاريع
تنميه بفرص
لحتى الذهاب والسفر والتنقل الى فرنسا
فستظل المساله ثقافيه دعائيه اكثر بنها اي
شيء اخر
انا اوافق زميلي همم المتحدث من تونس
اوافقه على ان اللغه الفرنسيه يجب ان
تتخيل مع مطالب هذه الشعوب في النمو في
تقدم وان تكون اللغه الفرنسيه اداء همم
لهذه البلدان لهؤلاء المواطنين في هذه
المناطق من الحصول على مؤهلات علميه تفيد
هذه البلدان وتنهض بها الى النمو تقدم اما
ان تكون اللغه الفرنسيه
لغه جميله نعم هذا شيء جيد لكن على اللغه
الفرنسيه ان تكون اداه تساعد هذه اللغه
هذه البلدان في ام تنمو تساعد هذه الشعوب
بان تخرج من الحاله التي هي فيها من من
تخلف ومن عدم تنميه في هذه البلدان انا
اوافق زميلي في في تونس على ضروره ان انت
تكيف هذه اللغه مع واقع هذه البلدان وان
تكون اداه
للنهوض والتقدم لنرى السيد
دميانسينام رايه في هذه النقطه تحت تحديدا
وهي محل توافق بين ضيفنا التونسي والشادي
يتفق عليه الجميع فقط
[موسيقى]
الضيوف تحدثوا كثير عن فرنسا ولانه قرر
الفرقونيه ليست مركزه فقط على فرنسا
ليست فقط مركز واحد هي عدت مراكز في خمسه
قارات وان المفهوم الجديد فقط
همم
تمنع التنميه الاقتصاديه
وكل الجوانب التي
تستطيع التنظيم اعلامي في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
لتحسين نوعيه نقل المعلومات
بالانجليزيه وهذا طلب بعض الاجراءات
لاعطاء الافضليه
والتنميه الاقتصاديه
والرسوله الحركه الجانب الاوسع
السباق على ذكر هذا السباق اللغه الفرنسيه
واللغه الانجليزيه هناك من يعتقد وانا
اسال باختصار رجاء الدكتور مهدي مبروك ان
هناك ايضا من يدافع داخل هذه الدول على
بقاء همم اولويه اللغه الفرنسيه مثلا
المؤرخ عامر خيله في في الجزائر يقول
الفرنسيه احب من احب كرهها من كره لها
وجود قوي في الجزائر ثقافي ولغه واجتماعي
ويقول انا من انصار تعميم اللغه
الانجليزيه ولكن لا يمكن للمزايده بالقول
ان الانجليزيه ستحل محل الفرنسيين هذا
الصراع بين الانجليزيه والفرنسيه في
المنطقه المغاربيه كيف ترى قبل ان نسال في
النهايه همم الصديق ابو بكر حول نفس
النقطه
نعم اكيد اللغه الفرنسيه تجدوا منافسه
شرسه مع اللغه الانجليزيه ومع مثلا في
تونس مع اللغه الالمانيه ايضا لدى
الجماعات العلميه الوادي الطلاب ولكن
اعتقد ان المساله ليست هي هذا الهوى
النفسي الذي ننتصر في هذه اللغه او اللغه
اخرى الامر موقول الى سياسات لغويه تاخذ
بعين الاعتبار المصلحه الوطنيه وتاخذ
اعتبار رغبه الجامعات وهياكل البحث العلمي
وايضا الفاعلين الاقتصاديين في تعدد
مبادلاتهم سواء كانت الرمزيه او المادي
انا مع التعدد اللغوي وليس مع احاديث
اللغه سوف كانت اللغه العربيه او
الانجليزيه او الفرنسيه ولكن في اعتقادي
ان السنوات القليله القادمه وما كانت
الوجود وربما الاجيال القادمه هي امييل
الى الهجره
الى الهجره حقيقه والى الهجره ايضا الى
اللغه الانجليزيه
ابو بكر باختصار رجاء
الحقيقه الحديث عن اللغه الانجليزيه
واللغه الفرنسيه نحن لا نتحدث عن احلال
لغه مكان لغه اخرى بقدر ما نحن نتحدث عن
تعدد لغوي او وجود لغه اضافيه الى ما هو
موجود الشعوب الافريقيه تتكلم الفرنسيه
لديها لهجات محليه في بعض الدول توجد
العربيه من جيبوتي الى السنغال اللغه
الفرنسيه همم تبقى همم
الى جانب هذه اللغات اذا ما ارادت ان ان
يكون لها وجود وجودها همم سوف لا تهدده
اللغه الانجليزيه يعني في وقت عاجل همم
كما ترون تطور اللغوي ياتي مع الوقت وهناك
اجيال واجيال تاتي ثم تتغير اللغات لكن
هنا الامر لا لا لا لا يتعلق باحلال لغه
اخرى نرى بعض الدول كل البنين مثلا بنين
دوله فرانكفورنيا الان
اللغه الانجليزيه الى جانب الفرنسيه
فرنسيه موجوده لكن اللغات الاخرى ستكون
موجوده ايضا الى جانب اللغه الفرنسيه لانه
الشعوب الافريقيه والشباب الجيل الجديد من
هذه في هذه الدول
شكرا لك صديق ابو بكر سلومه من
شكرا لضيفنا من باريس
دميانسيلا ولضيفنا من تونس مهدي مبروك
كالعاده في النهايه باختصار كبير تغريدات
في نهايه البرنامج نبدا بتغريده لجاك
التالي وهو كاتب فرنسي ومستشار سابق
للرئيس الراحل الفرنس وهو ميت راني يقول
في تغريدته لطالما حلمته بفران كفونيه
متكامله ومتضامنه مع اعضاء متساويين في
الحقوق مثل الاتحاد الاوروبي نحن بعيدون
جدا عن ذلك ومع ذلك نحن بحاجه ماسه الى
مشروعا بهذا الحجم لمصلحته كل من الشمال
والجنوب جفري وهو مواطن فرنسي يقول يشاركي
ايمانويل بنشاط كل يوم في تراجع اللغه
الفرنسيه في العالم انظر حسابه على تويتر
او خطاباته المتكرره باللغه الانجليزيه
سيئه بمجرد وجوده في الخارج
اما قناه الفرنسيه فنشرت تغريد جاء فيها
تمتد لف سفونيه في جميع انحاء العالم ولكن
ايضا في الفضاء قدمت وكاله الفضاء
الاوروبيه للتو فئتها الخامسه
والجديده لرواد الفضاء وهم خمسه من بينهم
بلجيكي وفرنسي وسويسري
في امان الله
[موسيقى]